well one interesting question for you
psychologically so because you
have become wealthy and because you give
like part of your work is giving away a
lot of money
um do you find it hard to find people
you can trust
is the question do do people see you
basically as a source of money as
opposed to another human being it's
weird because you would think yes but I
I feel like I also know the right places
to look
um but yeah if I just walked into Target
and try to make friends with 10 random
people of course
um so you gotta
uh so you can kind of sense oh yeah
that's the right thing and so quickly
yeah it does yeah that's yeah it's so
obvious so I don't even want to go into
descriptions but honestly a lot of my
friends are like uh Chandler I I played
Little League with him
um and Tyler the guy I mean I went to
school with him Chris he was my first
subscriber
um Carl was here after we got big but
whatever he's friends with the boys and
it is a lot of my closer friends even
like my YouTube friends I I knew before
I was big so
maybe there is some mirror to that maybe
it is I I don't know I've never really
put too much thought into it maybe
there's a reason I hang around a lot of
these people I knew before I got paid
because it's much easier and they help
you keep like uh your radar sharp of who
can and can't be trusted because you
know you can trust them yeah it's
difficult you become richer and richer
and more powerful well one thing
one time when you get rich not even
richer but more fan one thing I thought
is as I climbed this like ladder of
YouTube and got bigger I thought there
would be tons of people like me people
how to like that takes like the Kamikaze
approach to building a business you just
throw all your money in it you throw all
your time you throw all your energy
throw everything yeah you're just like
[ __ ] it this is this I'm dead yeah I
thought there would be hundreds of these
yeah and and there isn't there is I mean
there's like maybe one or two and I
talked to those [ __ ] every
single day I'm sick and tired of talking
to them but I love them
um but it's just so interesting because
like every level I got up like I get a
million subscribers like all right
where's all these guys in the million
subscribers that are [ __ ] Psychopaths
and then you know you know there are
people become like conservative as they
get like they get more especially as
they get bigger yeah and you know 20
million subscribers 30. it's like every
step of the way it's like I just got
more and more lonely to be honest but
you you know it sounds cliche and you
hear that kind of [ __ ] in movies and
you're like yeah that's not how it works
but it is like there's there's just not
many people that just want to give up
everything go all in and obsess over
making the greatest goddamn videos every
single day of their life like they're
really hard to find and be able to
sacrifice everything for that video yeah
like basically you put all the money
right back in yeah or the people doing
it they're on just a small scale and if
I talk to them it's just 99.9 of the
time I'm teaching them things and it's
like so it's lonely because there's not
too many people especially in the
creative space that are as crazy as you
yeah it is 100 it's it's so it's not
what I I was expecting I was expecting
there'd be a lot of people like me but
well I guess the guy we talked to Elon
Musk is a bit like you in that sense
yeah just in a different domain yeah
yeah exactly just willingness to put it
all back in right and that's why I found
right now a lot of the people I relate
to don't even make YouTube videos like
they're just like I I'm viewing more and
more away from fellow content creators
and more to just you know I'm just
looking for those other people who just
share a little bit of it so I don't feel
so [ __ ] crazy all the time like you
know what I mean
um and like people I feel normal around
and they tend to just be doing the
randomest things but you know loving it
well I think that's really inspiring
it's uh
it's like the Bukowski line to find what
you love and let it kill you is really
put everything
put everything into the thing you love
that that's like the way to really
create special stuff but it's also the
way to yeah
you have to be careful given this advice
because
they're like they're like bodybuilders
who'll be like just go to the gym be
disciplined I'm disciplined go to gym
but I would argue for those people it's
like it's not even discipline they just
enjoy weightlifting right if you because
there are people who are jacked but they
don't make much money or run a business
right if they're that disciplined they
would they would be hitting every area
of their life they just really like
business and there's people like me who
just to an extreme level love building
companies right it's not even
disciplined for me it's just in my blood
it's what I wake up I don't think about
it I don't push myself I don't need to
watch a [ __ ] motivational video to go
work I just do it it's programmed in me
at this point and I couldn't imagine a
world where I don't wake up and do it
every day
um but I think that a little bit of it
is genetics
um and just how you're hardwired uh not
that it can't be trained or taught and
not that you know and obviously the
friend group you're in influences these
things and over time I think can change
it but someone's just not gonna be able
to flip a switch and then just start
doing a kamikaze approach to building a
business just like a lot of people try
to flip a switch and start bodybuilding
and quit majority of the time you know
that's uh just not innate to them but I
think a lot of us have the capacity to
do that in some domain yeah I think if
you went about strategically if you
surrounded yourself with fellow
like-minded people and you know slowly
over time switched it uh but if you just
try to like hardcore do it you're just
going to lose your mind